[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle yeah
really good I'm gonna get some that's a
traditional Korean sausage so here you
have the traditional kimbap kind of food
is really tasty and really quick okay
this is one of the souvenir shops I'm
alright we're here
[Music]
sharing some tips of how to do modeling
more professional stay tuned I'm Maria
this is Daniel and this is my so
beautiful here
are you guys like this place tonight
yeah
[Music]
here's the clothes today some of the
accessories they are searching out the
clothes and then that's the makeup area
[Music]
hi I'm Daniel my name is Sarah hi sir
[Music]
visitor Brown we're shooting for today
maestro
and then these are the shoes that we can
wear with the brand so we're not
shooting for it but this is not just a
very very cool kind of shoes that will
fit in with most of the outputs and so
we have shoes here from Zara H&M Zara
Zara H&M
and then we have more Zara H&M H&M so
it's a mix of Zara and H&M and then we
have all do right over there as well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's lunchtime and this is a
traditional Korean food kimbap kimbap
it's kind of cool they have a except
kind of vegetables inside and then it's
rice and then it's bulgogi oh they're
all different
tuna okay okay they say this is a
offense but spicy so we're having a
little bit of a break now it's been good
so far very fast and
everybody's taking a break
we've got the hairstylist to makeup
artist and we got the stylist and
different Sagra fur which is five
minutes and then we're going back to the
coach
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right Sammy and Tim are out we're
out for a bike ride at the river there
is she's waiting for me
it's nice because like you guys remember
the the bike ride in China right this is
no space but here in Korea we followed
the rules so it's really nice to go for
a bike ride let's do this
[Music]
hey buddy man I like it even the kids
are biking so these are Tim's bikes
thanks then it's quite cool a lot of fun
[Music]
[Music]
the money of the pigeon there's no kids
here thank you
one of the key how do you say bon
appetit in that dream
I'm busted
no via bus game oh yeah yeah all right
[Music]
so I'm going for a pedicure yeah I have
a job tomorrow at the beach nice for
sandals and I want me to get a better
cure I've never had a pedicure in my
life you're gonna love so much of me but
alright let's go and go and do this
[Music]
[Music]
I'm very scared actually I'm very
ticklish
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not so bad
[Music]
like me
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I look very young I had to shake
[Music]
what's it called again mile me up I'm
gonna give it a try let's see it was
very strong very nice not bad
okay so this one is yes right very
traditional kind of beef and with rice
and a little bit of vegetables in here
okay here you read up try
pretty good
my I'm sorry I'm pretty good yes
[Music]
[Music]
hey ID okay it's three words what is
this he look at the first word second
word the opposite of low and then
knee-high socks okay I hate this line of
me Oh computer and what he's going to
study electronic what is this area
industry like the it's electronic oh
yeah it's like a long circle there's
DiCaprio yeah if you're not fat
Bremen ground beef comes in hmm if you
get in this less fat
what does this hit no brain yeah yeah
and era yes
[Music]
alright last day in South Korea we're
gonna go for a lunch we're gonna meet up
with Elizabeth
I'm gonna miss Mack so much that's what
was it then
[Music]
all right we made it we're here at the
restaurant we're gonna try the cold
noodles again max did not try that yeah
this place is famous check out all the
people in this community we're almost at
the front
Elizabeth's on the way she's running a
little bit of late five minutes but
she's gonna join us let's show you guys
how it looks like boys were inside try
to try those cold noodles yeah Elizabeth
joined us finally she rushed over here
but is here and this is it check out the
food I know what to expect but I'll try
[Music]
first you have to
and then you can add some vinegar or
Max is gonna try for the first time
[Music]
it's like all tumors
[Music]
so the last coffee I'm having with
Daniel Daniels favorite thing in the
world is coffee I thinks this is a
special moment so we're just done the
ice noodle was really good I collect it
and we just had some coffee and now I
have to say goodbye to Elizabeth a
little bit sad getting out a little bit
a lot
the worst thing about modeling and
traveling meet cool people and then you
have to say goodbye I'm one of those
people and take a text you know all
right we are leaving the coffee shop and
I miss you Dan bruh
thank for teaching me the ways of life
and I'm sure when I see you again
rebirth gonna be more established from
this life that we are creating for
ourselves and our different lanes but
yeah brothers for life
so we're leaving we're gonna get a taxi
[Music]
just go with the flow
man it's emotional climate if you if you
leavin you just have to say goodbye to
everybody it's not fun not fun I think
the worst is when I have to say goodbye
to this guy grew very close and man I
don't want to say I'm out of words just
emotional anyway we're near to two and a
half weeks together but I feel like it
was two and a half months connected
really well and I'm showing you see each
other again it's gonna be a special
moment
so I got a new brother yeah I lost two
brothers in my life but man life is so
interesting I'm gaining another brother
yeah just in two and a half weeks
[Music]
are you still here goodness I'm happy
you came to say goodbye though for
having your everything we have to thank
you so much for everything and being
kind and hospitable and - it was good
take care of yourself and but let's stay
in contact maybe we can do some more
collaboration for a few years and stuff
yeah okay
[Music]
mara light saying goodbye friends
[Music]
whoo yeah brother Daniel
once I think enough over the last two
and a half weeks everything you've shown
me talk to me about Saul and you've been
like my big brother over here and we
made a lot easier for me to make the
transition so I really do appreciate it
and ya are just reconfirms in my mind
that you meet everyone for a reason I
never really used to believe that up
until about a year ago when I started
modeling and meeting the lovely people
all along the journey that I do and you
reconfirm that yeah we're gonna have a
common way to see you again and make
some more videos and chat about our
paths but now it's time to say goodbye
[Music]
guys they didn't really meet any of the
the Booker's just Maya but this is mo
he's driving us to the castings all the
time
max for the Dan oh man thank you not
this time thank you for everything thank
you for that man
we have to stay in contact or favor big
city life stay safe travel safe
relaxing with your family being make the
most of that week bruh this is too
emotional guys yeah yeah petitions got
[Music]
you